if your life was a movie what would be
the turning point for you prison because
I remember lying when I was 19 with not
a clue what I was gonna do when I came
out when I was in there
and they locked the door your liberty is
gone I remember something I said I was
never ever come back to a place like
this
my mum was and my dad my stepdad smoked
a lot of weed my mum drank a lot it was
a very intense house to be in because my
stepdad he didn't like me where did the
love for football stop can you remember
that moment oh I think that that's when
people liked me because I knew I was
good at that stage eight nine starts I
was really good that's when the love
came because it's something that I was
good at it that's a bit rude [__] though
innit when you think about that your
love of football came from feeling like
accepted because that's what you've been
missing earlier on but David roecastle
death it's something that I don't think
I'll ever get over the hard thing about
it was the phone calls when I think of
the phone calls you go back to your
childhood you think back to when he was
nine and ten because I can't I can't
deal with the fact that her face for he
was gone I'm very god-fearing you know I
mean I had to because my mum wasn't we
had to do with that system that's when I
had my arguments with with God to makes
you question life month it really does
it does and the thing is is that with
with religion and all that sort of stuff
you have to have faith this is why I do
feel very fortunate with the way it's
gone for me you know I mean honestly now
got a missus my two little girls you
know I've got a missus that is just
amazing she's perfect
I just want to be remembered for the
part for the person that got the
opportunity and did the very I rang it
out
I rang it out there's nothing left in
that right to squeezer and that's all I
want to be remembered for
what's the cord you see with our people
don't understand is that when you're
when we're in a match of the day office
you know when you see our doodles rants
he says Annette this that dude he's not
you know that he's not he's not Vic's
with rapper he's not vet sort of
pleasure
he's vex with the fact that the
situation can't get any better and he
can't really do you can't really do and
say too much but like this is the man
honestly you know what it means to
Newcastle you know she is this God up
there you know
I love it I love when I go up as I saw
is that Shearer Alan Shearer away us
people don't understand right
like Arsenal they've got all the legends
are on the stadium
yeah we couldn't do that in you
compliment we have they're just beefier
pretty much yeah but you know what's
really what's really quite sad for me
right is seen where the statue had to be
situated yeah what was that about
it's well obviously it's got to have
something to do with your man yeah it's
not manly
yeah well change the name of the bar was
sheer as more yeah him name and then for
it to be outside where it is down a road
a little bit yeah it should mean you're
right should be on the [__] and right
I mean like you know like Michael
chuckling I mean [__] Michael Jeffrey
just train them as good as full of like
Michael Jackson is it too much to treat
her like Fulham treated like a dog he
sighs especially and they're making a
new documentary about Michael Jackson
with HP offing seriously like afterwards
that that that Wade guy who Utah have a
dance he was one who did all the X [__]
that dance routine so sort of right all
right and he's in it because he
previously went to the trial and was I
know I never did know yeah and now he's
in the documentary and the people are
saying he's gonna be like well I lied
huh and like so coffee there's no you
can do now but yeah but a thing is not
gonna be impressing like and with
Michael Jackson net you know because he
means so much to me when I was growing
up mmm I got any person that Michael
Jackson just got them people kids and
young surround the house to literally
because we're talking about a grown man
as a child he's a genie
but he's and like to literally show off
and do stuff like this is my giant candy
floss machine you can you can eat candy
floss all day it was when the cleaners
came out and started being like oh yeah
like [__] went down that I was like
because I grew up loving Michael Jackson
yeah it's so weird you just the same
yeah better thing is as as like like
Bill Cosby a [__] man that was the worst
one monitor what's talking about one of
the one of the greatest you know he came
through what he you know I mean when he
came through to cut the comedy side and
and you know you have people like
Richard Pryor saying things like you're
not mean yeah you know I mean he he's
digging out Eddie Murphy for swearing
and doing this and that in his concerts
its drugging women struggling women you
know I mean people and it was well known
it was well known that like people would
say you know two women are working on in
the production crew of him watch him
don't go near him mmm-hmm it's well
known so why why didn't we were just out
him and he was like the American Dad the
ultimate like horses man
yeah the Cosby's was the ultimate like
family show where you watch it with the
all the morals and all the the the the
stories and you know it was like you
think you said God all my talk about
absolutely [__] just did just destroy
your whole childhood perception of the
guy dislike him ignore Kelly man oh yeah
I'll cut it he's got a [__] document
it's like we can't have people you can't
hold anyone up like everyone everyone's
getting [__] accused or there's
something
Ronaldo's got some [__] [__] going on
in the background Chris Brown's just had
someone exactly getting them arrested
there's rumors about another sports star
and I'm not even gonna mention who that
is but you know we've all seen the
what's up crew you know you listen to
the songs you even the songs
you're not my mind's telling me no but
my
listen up a little your body another one
mate
[__] help me I mean what's wrong with
you knock one out right now you can't
have idols anymore you know you can't do
that thanks for the coffee's thanks a
lot he's not actually the coffee boy
okay it's just yeah he's just a good lad
like that is anything I could choose God
will be Brian it will be the frame side
of it I think it's the most overrated
fing in the world 100% frame is
overrated if I could do YouTube without
it I would be more than happy you know
it's very it's very much overrated let
me take this out yeah I didn't know how
long you liked it well how does how does
a man take his tea it's so personal you
making my tea you just sort of hit the
ground running as you'd expect I
realized that ladies and gentlemen true
jody podcast guests the legend that one
of my favourite footballers of all time
but to be honest with you not because of
what you were like on the pitch you were
a great footballer but your personality
like you appeal to me as Jack the lad
piss tick and hyper large you know I'm
in a bit of bun how about you and you of
all among us say of North fence but
Michael Lauren's you just I was saying
to somebody the other day it was my the
rejection from from the age of light I
started playing at eight the rejection
from the age of 12 I think and you know
I mean I trusted like wrote all the
London club's our trials with Palace and
and Charlton and stuff like that and
Orion didn't get answers from the rest
of them didn't make any trials and so I
played for Sunday morning foot one he
just it's all about jokes and fun and
trying to score great goals and you know
afterwards drinking you know bloggers in
lime you know I mean you brought like
that work
in months our 'true to the gate I feel
like that's dead I remember I played
against Artie Artie pool and you know
this is when I was in at my Heights at
Arsenal and one of the players I think
his name was Magoo king or something
like I can't remember but like he was
just waiting the tunnel and he's saying
[__] giving big Thomas a big toss
about to [__] walk out in front of
3,000 course it's big time you said
you're a Sunday morning players I know
but now play for us though you know I
mean I said to him that's not actually
said to my words play nice score
actually in the game I actually said to
him while I was playing it's actually
you know he couldn't give he couldn't
have paid me a bigger compliment
I'm Sunday morning footballer he's now a
professional footballer but I've never
lost my Sunday morning roots you know I
mean going out all night on Saturday and
then going straight to this game on a
Sunday morning and this is why I didn't
think I was any good because obviously
got rejected so many times in the trials
and I was playing against like pub
blokes and scoring four and five goals
and this is where I suppose I honed that
just try anything
just try anything finish anything what
comes into your head and I never never
stop now when I went to Palace Steve
Coppell said that never change how you
what you are was signed in for what you
are now home that you know in your plane
at that level like that not the palace
of all at the Sunday morning level did
people come over to afterwards and go
you got something special no no no no
what it was is that people knew of me
because everybody in the community in
all around knew that I had trials and
knew I was good and there's always
competitions like there was a supermalt
competition where literally every black
team in and around London would go to
rains Park and it would be like a World
Cup competition for that weekend and you
know I mean a lot of people will come
and watch me because everybody's heard
of this guy playing sunny Molly's not
bad scoring for him four goals a game
and it's really weird because I played
in it from the age of like 16 to 21 and
we got to the we got to the final at
went when I was 20 21 and I get excited
the palace I can't play in the final
absolutely gutted and the Panda final
was at mitchum Trek Crystal Palace's
training ground supermarket at halftime
super the world to be honest and
nutriment right yeah obviously I've done
a
research onion one thing that support
well it kind of seemed the creeping at
one point the self-doubt like open when
it all went tits up bright yeah it
seemed like you were just say like what
was the like because we're looking at
you you've had such a career but it
might not have happened it was on a
knife action absolutely so close you not
being sucky on being this guy so what
what was that so nobody heard you
describe what it was that actually got
you there to go and try out for
Christopher bright and mostly it was
luck cuz the Brighton was a really low
time was just not long and not long come
out of prison for driving offenses and
so I was low as it was Sean was
something like sure I just adopted Sean
you know I mean adopting short I even
didn't even have a penny on me but you
know I mean it was a situation where I
think that that was my lowest point came
out of prison my mom didn't want me in
and around the house anymore so I moved
out that's when I moved in with Sharon
but that was probably my lowest point
there's so much to dissect this or so
you went the president it was a short
period of time
yeah when infraworks outs about 21 days
for non-payment of fines because I I had
two cars when I was 17 with no papers no
tax 19 no insurance people have asked me
a hawk so Viva an Fiat 125 brown and
beige no bumpers on the front worth it
and worth the prison plastic yeah you
know something you say that bribe but
the fact is is that that 21 days in
prison because we'd never been in
trouble to please any of my family apart
for my brother frame milk bottles in a
lift and they got in trouble from the
police with other than that but the
thing is is that in and around that time
when I was we're not when I came out his
it shaped me it made me realize because
I'm not a thief I'm not somebody that's
interrupting robbery
I've got to work didn't do well enough
in school left school at 13
just just turning 14 went straightened
onto a building site the first thing I
do when I left school and I was 14 was
it was I had to turn like they've got
three
balus and we had to do a foundation in a
house and I - literally looking mix-up
in three yards of cement on my first day
for tea you're not a big lad either like
it for in you must I'm you know I'm
gonna talk like a child I was I was
skinny
I was very skinny but you know they and
when you do the bonding for the plaster
in which the guy was trying to teach me
they've got a whisker now you could risk
it yet to do that with a stick right so
by the time you finished yeah and that's
what I finished doing that free yards of
balance my back was his little he's like
jelly but you know when I was walking I
could literally couldn't walk because my
back was like jelly and it made me
realize well that was when I was
fourteen I said jeez I can't do this is
too [__] hard and that's when you
realized Jesus Christ I never I never
done well enough in school I'm gonna be
manual labor and it took me all that
time up to when I came out prison to say
right I'm gonna try and fight find the
trade and do the plastering the
brickwork stuff and that's what I tried
when I came out of prison that's what I
went to try and do so young mother was
like stay away from the house what was
your relationship with like with her
before then what was when was younger
cuz my mum my mum was and my dad my
stepdad smokes a lot of weed my mum
drank a lot it was very it was a very
intense house to be in because my
stepdad he didn't like me
my older brother came from Jamaica when
he was like ten we didn't really bond my
brother Maurice who's my immediate to me
was the one who you know I mean he's my
guy he was the one it was very it was
rough rough in the house you know it was
a time I remember one of the stories
that people always come up to me and
they hug me to say about not being able
to watch much of the day because I had
to turn to the wall while he heard the
music
so telly would be there and the bed we
lived in one bedroom one bedroom room we
had in the house and the bed will be
here and you just say turn round turn
out to walk so you couldn't actually
watch it so it was that kind of stuff
and then you know I mean you can you
imagine you to me it just cruel for the
sake of it just for the sake of it just
cause he could and that was one of the
biggest feet my brother used to when
they used to be fighting an argument
brother would color that's my ears so I
couldn't hear it because it would make
you cry and it was that kind of it was
always
quite a volatile place until they
finally broke up and left and that sort
of stuff but he's he's daughter mice my
sister Dion she was a nightmare we'd be
in a room and like if it's just me and
her and like my mum and she'd just gone
and come in but wouldn't even ask the
question my mom just quit something like
that and she would do that right on a
regular basis because she knew she'd get
away with that so the the household was
was quite suppressive because obviously
I couldn't I was very violent when I was
young I was ready to fight like that BAM
so because my brother would hold you
down and hold me down to the point where
I think he's gonna choke me out and then
just let you go and then my other
brother would do the same thing because
I was so I just like I just try and
steam into him and get see if I could
get a punch in before they do what they
do so when I went outside and then I saw
I couldn't I couldn't get no joy from a
brother in his face or anything my
stepdad was giving me a nightmare my mum
would clip me my older brother would
choke me out my other brother would
practice choking out choke me out my
sister would act like I've just working
done something to her so you go outside
and you play funny but you start playing
football if anyone touches actually
Bampton a devil just fighting everyone
where did where did the love for
football
stop can you remember that moment or
what we used to gonna stay with my
cousins in Hatfield and I remember they
called me little Pelle and this is when
I was like eight I went to at field and
you know when I think that that's when
people liked me when I played when I
played football everybody's on that side
we're running on our side and when I
really like when I was because I knew I
was good at that stage eight nine to
start I was really good you know this is
why it was such a nightmare when I
didn't get into any finger people used
to tease me about it
but that's when the love came because
it's something that I was good at yeah
and even like to it once my brother
started watching me bake see oh that's a
bit rude [__] though innit when you
think about that your love of football
came from feeling like accepted because
that's what you'd been missing earlier
on
like maybe maybe in the thing about it
is is that when I had to latter stages
and I had to start seeing a counselor
about anger issues a lot of its tend
back to there once you know because when
I went there for the first couple of
months just lied
I just went in and never even told her
the truth you know I mean she said stuff
to you live and then I mean one time
when we sat there and I must have didn't
say anything for maybe 25 minutes and I
was like I just endless Annie and your
pain you're paying very good money to do
this if you're gonna come here and lie
because honestly when she said it I was
like you know you get you know you feel
like she's in your head and as and she
said that and then to be honest when she
said that [__] burst into tears and I
just blasted it I told her what
literally what I told you know it's made
a lot easier for me to be able to to
share with people now because either I
went through a lot of problems with it
because my mum and all the family and
everybody was saying once I started
telling them yeah my mum drank a lot and
when I started to go to when I went to
ask Laura I used to go to the steps with
people like Tony and and and and Merce
you know friends of Bob that used to go
to their meetings and they used to ask
me star and used to I used to tell them
you know my mama needs to say well you
know you should see if you can get her
in it
you know I mean it is one of those
situations where the family [__] they
hated me
especially when was it came out remember
that nothing to something yeah well a
documentary where my face is history
when that came out [__] family just
literally just went BAM [__] you because
I told the truth you know I mean there's
a lot of stuff that was happening when I
was younger people telling me how much
they hated me if you're gonna bring the
kids around
don't bring the little one was the thing
they used to say you know I mean some of
the time to adult someone's out and you
smash something off at a table and you
know my mum would argue you know I mean
so it was it was really it's one of
those things it's just good friends with
a woman who so 56 years old Sheila says
to me you should always respect children
because one day you might wish you had
have done mm-hmm and I feel like this is
a classic case of that you know because
some that kid in the corner eventually
grows the other thing is Brian it's like
you say that and it's [__]
happened is happened in my life all of
sudden everybody was shunning you not
enough to do when I broke through it
palace and we'll talk about how I
actually got into Palestine all of a
sudden I've turned into the major I got
a family I was the one I was in charge
of everybody looking at me like I'll be
at home in a Sunday we play a game and
be on a Sunday it'd be like [__]
people rolling up to Don Corleone it was
yes it was it turned into look at the
child like the Bob Marley song the
cornerstone and a builder refuses in the
morning becomes the head cornerstone in
the evening that is actually exactly
what happened to me I became the most
important thing in the family when you
were so going back to when you were a
kid there's a video that a lot of people
asked me to mention and that's the
teacher video he's a big mister picton
yeah and it's just an emotional because
I we all want someone who believes in us
and the first person ever bright you
seem to be that person because that's
man as well first man yeah absolutely
lost the first man and this is why you
know I still have moments where like
even I say you know with my goals when
when he realized when I started playing
football and he saw that I could play he
was the one who told me about told me
about Jimmy Greaves and passing into the
neck giving the goalkeeper no chance
score a beautiful goal Ian what a
goalkeeper can't blame anyone he can't
even dive you know that's what he'd
always say to me but I remember the
first time we met his I had problems in
the classroom with paying attention it
seriously you know as soon as I didn't
get what they were saying I've kind of
got disruptive I was clear and I'd get
put outside the classroom and what I
changed and and why it was is that a
couple of times mr. pignon would walk
past and he was he always looked so
smart dark suits he had those black
oxford shoes on and what was really
shiny because he was an army major he
was a pilot and in India in Royal Air
Force always smart and he walked past me
and look me and remember I'm so small
and he's the person this is why even
when you mentioned
his name it makes me get myself right
fix your business up mm-hmm
because I was I like this and he went in
the classroom on about the third
occasion he saw me out there and he went
in and spoke to mrs. dance and when he
came out he just came out to follow me
come with me and so I came went with him
and from then he had me as like he gave
me private tuition it was almost like
I'm invited to read though the books
Roger to read Gregory a green and
Benjamin the blue you know I used to
read those books cuz I was really
struggling in my writing wasn't great
for a seven-year-old and he just sorted
me all sorted everything out when I
started playing football and when I used
to when I used to get angry he'd take me
off off off and it's an understandably
like crying cause if you're losing if I
was losing I'd start crying and I start
lashing out and he's the first person
that would say and count to ten count to
ten as it worked and I thought do you
want to go back on oh god yes I didn't
stop crying well when you stop crying
you could go back on yeah just try to
stop [__] crying when you chat with
you everything has to stop me to say
everything until the point I was like
listen him say you're running out time
but he did say it's double and then I
get us off calm and it calmed me down
and they're not gonna pitch and play he
was the first person that really showed
caring and love that way from a man a
man that showed and really it he
invested in me and so so that's that
that's the background of him so I was
doing a television program where I
couldn't find him for two three years
and the teachers couldn't get in touch
with them everybody else it said now
we've not seen him with we're not sure
where as we think he may have passed
because we've not heard we're talking
about two three years trying to find him
and it was difficult very difficult cuz
I couldn't get in touch with none of the
old teachers even from the school I
couldn't find people and so it's one of
those and I just remember that I had to
do this television program and there was
talking to me about and I said yeah I
think he's passed away because you know
I've been trying to get rid of it get in
touch of him for four years and no one
could find him
and obviously the television television
people found him and you know I was
there
speaking about stuff and then he just
came from behind me and what you know
the first thing I thought I just took my
hat off and because it was so surprising
to see him and he said Ian how are you
what just [__] Phil I'm gonna go now
and because he was like free free stick
oh you look like a giant I was still
yeah so I was hugging him and I was
round his waist and he was saying things
I I'm so proud of you
you've done really well Anderson I said
I thought he was dead and he said well
I'm very much alive no and it was a
situation where after that we stayed in
touch but I remember he came to watch me
he what he didn't want to mate he didn't
make a fuss didn't want to come
somewhere again came to a couple of
games I remember he saw he saw a game I
scored it's a palace I think was playing
against Brighton and it was a game where
we there was like five penalties in a
game or something and I scored and left
foot shot what every time we spoke he
always he always talked about it but the
thing about him was is that he was one
of the pilots that when we'd won the
Second World War
he's one used to talk to me about the
trenches and people going over the top
he was one of the pilots chosen as the
18 pilots did a flyover Buckingham
Palace and he said that when I played
for England it was the proudest moment
of his life because all he wanted to do
is teach and you know I mean to be be
the pupil that made him realize that
teaching is all he wanted to do that was
Dutch that was beyond me to company even
now reminds me of recent you have to
Mike Tyson interview of jørgen in yeah
watch that just just make in customer
door happy what's all he wanted it
wasn't really about that as much as just
making up making someone like your
mentor happy assigned ultimate goal I I
don't think you can and he's the one no
matter what was I just wish that he was
in and around me
more for my hedonistic years oh yeah you
know because you mighta listen to him
I probably would have because like I say
going back to all of a sudden my
guidance from a young age wasn't good
didn't get good guidance from a stepdad
my older brother Morris tried with me
but by later it didn't work I didn't get
good guidance so you know looking around
at people and you know people had
girlfriends were over the place it was
it wasn't I didn't have the upbringing
that could guide me let me realize that
this isn't this isn't the way I
personally I was raised without my dad
was doing my life but kind of not really
I said I feel it's really hard to become
a man without having like man who's
there to put in go you you know like you
never [__] shut up yeah yeah and I
knew that yeah I became a worse person
for having like that you know I said
when Pinocchio's in before the jackasses
like you know you turn into one yourself
yes you do and I think I needed a good
hide in a few times oh well it's a
business it was one of those situations
where I remember um I started to when it
would have been like 16 17 s where I got
a good idea from a guy who turned out to
be turning to my best mate one of my
best mates name was Carl he's a really
good footballer we played in his super
mall together and you know I mean
because I was the guy and everybody knew
I was a guy playing for 10 MB and was
playing at the park and I was doing my
stuff and then me and car like this kind
of altercation they're not kind of went
over to like [__] would you not like
everybody to a man you know I mean
obviously they wanted to say I was
alright in that but so everybody said
you [__] deserve that you mean you've
had that coming for a long time because
what was happening was is that while I
was getting more and more prominent in
the non-league football Sunday morning
game it's getting a bit too [__] full
of myself you know I mean it's getting
too full on so because I was scoring two
and three goals a game you know I mean I
was on a messy kind of [__] thing in
a non league brother League message yes
not only as a non league messy blur the
podcast
you know the thing is that I didn't
actually this is why this is where the
finishing and not bothering about how to
finishing when I've got into the
professional game I didn't care about I
tried things because the worst thing
that's gonna happen once I realize in a
professional game is people are gonna go
oh oh they're gonna [__] you think oh my
god unbelievable go so there's no
downside to trying things and that's
where it came from scoring all those
goals
and Sunday morning football but like I
said I didn't think I was any good so I
wasn't really having myself but I've got
bigger got stronger you know I mean some
of the times we'd have to we'd go into
places like Deptford Thamesmead like the
farrier estate and sid like rough areas
involving rough areas and you're talking
about old Black team set the [__]
goalkeeper of course we had a go key
made he was the one always kicked off a
goalkeeper because obviously say
something to my [__] [__] lover or
something like that underneath the [__]
you know and then everyone in it steams
it we used to have to leave places it
was like King Warriors getting out of
some of these places in the car parks
people running battles in the car it's
mental innit
it's meta good people take [__] so no
literally it just Marv you win or lose
lots ago really for this when you go to
and you know you literally you know that
you're you're planing it in an area
where it's just Millwall supporters yeah
the middle supporters come down because
they're Millwall fans were playing you
ended up your end up fighting you end up
having running battles to get out of
debt fur to get out of it fine did you
enjoy that
yeah anything it was something that I
think it kind of catered to that anger
inside because light was me I met my
best friend Conrad was playing at time
we could have a row Freddie Steve Elka
you know Tony Palmer you know it means
like Daryl Palmer
you know Steve change like Steve
chambers you know I mean these people
wanted to fight they wanted to fight you
know I mean so it was one of those
situations where you knew that once it
kicks in BAM everyone's in is all in so
gone from that to Crystal Palace yeah it
was was that like
almost perfectly shape you because then
when you get that level you're like
we're not [__] fighting after this
game for a meal few drinks this is nice
you know what was good is is that when I
remember I got into pilot is 85 mmm
people still kind of giving you a little
bit of abuse and racial abuse and stuff
like that where did you think it
yourself yeah oh yeah it was something
that was very easy to deal with when
you're when you're right there and
you're hardened to it now yeah he was
because like that I didn't realize that
there I honed all my what I needed for
the professional game apart from the
fact that I had that red mist I could go
like that that was something that I had
to control all the way through but in
respects of getting wound up on a Sunday
they couldn't say anything to me and
from a professional level that's gonna
bother me more than these guys sit on a
Sunday morning who were literally
rocking jumping off [__] it's too
[__] tackle yeah you know so I wasn't
really afraid you know so I found it
very very easy to take but out right in
your face from the angry crowd just
giving you stick was one of the things
that was like that was when that
happened to you for the first time a
real proper like what we see range so a
real proper blast of racism
it [__] stops you in your tracks yeah
because obviously I've got no [__]
idea what that's like from every angle I
don't know it could be a football I
don't know it could be a black foot I've
gotten so what what's the actual emotion
that goes through your body at that
point that's a stripping of your that's
a stripping of you as a person that
unless you experience rape like a real
being racially abused you can't really
get into his almost is it's making you
feel like you're standing there naked
and people are just it's being stripped
of all your dignity because you've got
to be the person that stands there and
takes that and turn the other cheek like
white me for King said I mean because
you have to do that steep up to this day
and it's it's a feeling that it doesn't
just like that so it has
and you carry on playing and it's fine
because if that is with you all the time
you're playing mm-hmm you know I
remember hearing Paul cannibals said he
stopped warming up close to the lines he
wound up in the middle of the pitch so
he didn't have to get it it's it's
something that you just can't you I
can't explain it
oh you mustn't bro the boys it's a hard
one to deal with I watch the documentary
that you did yeah it was shocking for me
like because I really my first game I
went to was 1987 Newcastle and I run at
that game someone called David Ginola
a [__] French [__] and I remember
going to my mom like well that's not
very nice but that was as close as I'd
heard this as bad as it got yeah pretty
bad but he was having a party the thing
is when I watched your documentary I was
like wow I to me it felt like it was way
way further away I don't know how close
how close it was to the present day how
bad it was it like you say that Brian
even we would like Rusk on my man on my
manager on that now we we we still get
in people saying to us they are so
grateful we know we've already changed
we've changed the attitudes of young
kids because when they saw that and saw
we're talking about what 40 years maybe
of racial abuse and go further back and
then they you go further back and then
what they've done they've gone further
back to find out what's going on and
brought herself up to speed they know
how wrong that is so it's done something
in that respect to make and that's how
you're gonna have to deal with Reysol
you're gonna have to grow it out of
people it's gonna have to be growing out
of generations and that is what you do
you just got to put a show like this so
people can see it you know all you get
as a black person if you if you
highlight racism you you will be accused
of playing a race card and I here we go
again
people feel like me as a black guy I've
got the answers it's not simple racism
is complex it goes back far this is why
when you see all the sudden you get some
a black guy go on a radio for four
it's to try and talk about it apart from
Tom Barnes who was magnificent on a
familiar-looking fact is is that what
you need is that a longer period of time
people got to know that there's not a
lot of anger in it from black people
yeah when you've got people who can
speak eloquently about it and concisely
different time as well back in 85 that's
in 85 because you could be overtly
racist and people wouldn't bat an eyelid
in the same way on the TV this is why
this is why where we are now of course
we've we've moved on because the mere
fact that you you're outraged thinking
my god did he just say that these are
like respected yeah yeah you saw John
Barnes and Peter busier under a sign at
the NF sign on it yes that's how much we
accepted accepted it and so you know
it's a situation where you know like I
said it will be something as long as
people are not afraid to talk about it
you know I mean you can't speak about
with people who are closed off because
they want an answer right now
okay get Ian right one okay so so what's
I can't answer that just because I've
been racially abused I haven't got the
answers for racism for me it's always
seemed and this is just where I looked
at it for someone who's never suffered
it but people generally fear difference
in some way shape or form yeah and this
is just a really nasty horrible dark
version of that it's like they're the
worst possible form of that and the more
will you keep speaking like this the
better a baby that's that's all it is is
you know people being able to to like
myself a black guy be able to just speak
about racism in this kind of forum so as
people don't feel like you you have to
be embarrassed about it because it's
enough to be embarrassed about if you
are ignorant towards took towards it and
you don't know you need to educate those
people there's a kind of like a new form
it feels and we're getting or skipping
around all sort it so well you mentioned
Raheem Sterling it the papers seem to be
you know Horning in on him for that
reason and it's like you know it's bad
enough when people are in the [__]
Stan's do but when they've got been
respected suppose it you know journals
are at it how does that make you feel
because you're kind kind of you're a
journalist now really yeah yeah I feel
when you look at the way Rahim is
treated in there and the fact is now
that Rahim and the guys and black guys
have got platforms now where they can
answer themselves and you saw being done
with these posts and what what that done
it made the journalists and people think
more and in depth about what they write
and how they they word what they're
saying but alas do you genuinely think
it did or do you think because because
they had to realize long as what they
were saying and how they said it even
when you looked at that piece and the
way one of the black the black guy was
portrayed from before buying a for
splashing out two and a half million
splashes out on the house you know
25,000 pounds a week and Manchester City
player splashing out on a house for mum
and then you've got the Phil folding
footballer by his house by those three
in I mean you know and that is what
Rahim has shown a light on and you know
when people saw those in isolation you
feed yourself okay and you so you look
at Lawrence and you think yourself well
that's a little bit of a difference in
the way that they're explaining the kids
stories the thing that strikes me is
like racism since you know watching
you're watching your documentary and
seeing how avert it was has found more
subtle ways of being racist which is why
they never went this black guy bought it
nice car a bingo Raheem Sterling we all
know what he's then he didn't wash it
[__] Trump that's the point is like
the implications of those things and
it's the silent implications those
things you that that's hard to fight
because you can't come in and go racist
because they were not being racist
because pointing something out that's
almost as bad as being like plug in
whatever you know killer you know
something I let's say so it is probably
controversial but I think that when you
think of racism and racism and how far
it goes back and out its intrinsic it's
in the DNA of people and that's passed
down the different generations and you
almost get hmm you almost get the
feeling that it's almost like he's just
let's make sure he's knows his place
that's that's that's what it is I
remember my grundle say to me look black
people are lazy and things I'm not
member being like why is it like not but
as a kid
luckily for me I was smart enough to
realize he's a [__] idiot so
granddad's are lazy too but like I mean
it does get pasta it does pasta yeah and
you know I mean this is why when you say
the ignorance of it mmm if you reach the
right poet so if you reach you you're
gonna be fine
and then when we reach you then you're
gonna tell Sam you say well to be honest
that's bollocks because of it and then
you'll be able to reach and teach
another one but like in respects of
someone like I say like Rahim and the
way the point I made about like stay in
your lane
almost you know know your place it's got
that vibe about it the way it's done and
like you've mentioned then I was just
subtly done you know I mean we're
talking about somebody who with with his
childhood and everything was gone on you
know with his father and and and the
fight that he's had to get where he is
and let's face it at the moment Raheem
Sterling's playing a brand of football I
didn't think you'd get to the level of
when he was a little you see improvement
but he is actually he is absolutely
brilliant right now so that the journeys
had up to this point where everything
was going on behind the scenes and the
personal the personal journey is much
more interesting than the car not being
washed shopping at Primark you know I
mean all this bother us what comes on
these of us these this story what he's
got where he's got to where he is now
it's so inspiring and not just for black
kids for everybody because he's gone for
a journey which has been very very
difficult but they do like to harp on
the negativity of the so-called
stereotypical young black guy with money
cars having a good time too we see all
players at some stage having parties
doing stuff but they really focus on him
in that way and that's why when I
mentioned it and I thought it go too
long about it because you can't get
really hard for people to listen to when
you're talking about races but it's not
simple and this is what I'm saying but
what you want is for people to just just
to treat him fairly and this is why when
you say about how they wrote wrong it is
it was it team yes its tinge of racism
and we've just
except that says we can move on because
one thing I were not my first job
actually in in football was with you
football journalism you and I film
together
I knew you'd find a wig really the
interesting side of it was that every we
have do Breann we had Clinton Morrison
all these players who everyone went I
looked up to me am right am right was my
hero and then there's there's a video a
night video of you taking like Raheem
out to like some chip shop or something
a chat with him yeah it does seem very
much the way you speak now you can even
tell you're a bit of a mentor for all
these people sometimes moves past
knowledge on yeah was that something you
consciously did or was it like just that
people come to you that you know and
just be like Ian I don't know what to do
how did you deal with what in respects
of role model yeah like every black
player we've ever spoken to has always
said Ian Wright was of a certain
generation always goes in writes the man
cuz okay I came from a similar
background to them and what they've seen
is that my personality of course you
know I mean I've not my edges off I know
exactly how to be in certain situations
but I'm exactly who I am I still I still
am Ian Wright came from Sunday morning
football and realizes I was very
fortunate to to get the chance I've got
and took it but I don't changed the way
my personality is you know that's that's
what they recognized and they recognized
as well that you can do it as well you
know it sounds very obvious that people
say yeah but that's why I've talked it
in right because he came from the same
kind of place and I realize that Ian's
rights they're doing it so I can do it
and that is as simple as it is and so
what you do is you want to try and make
sure that you're blasting the path what
you're doing how you see it I'm not
going to try and say all I'm not gonna
do that because if I do that then
they're going to do I'm doing what I'm
doing and I will make mistakes but what
you've gotta understand is that you have
to be able to be in a position where you
can speak up about stuff so as they are
not afraid to get to the same level and
realize that yes there is certain things
that you can lose by speaking out and
speaking your mind about certain things
that might be quite
Frick's like friction cause friction
with people but if you believe it
and it's the truth for telling you have
to stand by and I've just always try to
be very true to myself what I'm doing
I've made a lot of mistakes but like my
heart and the way I am and the people
all got around me they not everything's
in the right place this is why when you
use certain things that come from social
media in respects of abuse and it
doesn't it doesn't matter on some
impervious to its and that's where I
comes laughing and smiling because they
don't know me and when I speak to those
guys I said you've got to be true to
yourself because if you're not it will
will come to the light you know I mean
but just do what's right always you know
like that about you because you never
you've never I don't know if you've ever
I'm sure there's been times where you've
been challenged to keep a hold of who
you really are
yeah especially with all that money and
all that fame but you've definitely
maintained that and you're definitely
there now it was one football I feel
right right now it's not a sort of
amount of the people the way you are in
that's real Ferdinand I think some of
the things he's been saying lately I
know you're kind of me yes I wanna bring
it up he's he's obviously being shot and
[__] about Newcastle no that's fine like
they say people are going to make
mistakes and yeah but me main
frustration with him as a pundit is the
fact that when he had the thousands of
Twitter yeah basically saying this is
why you are this is my room this way and
he was clearly wrong I'm not even gonna
guide into is wrong because we have a
[__] day but the point is is his
attitude rather as a professional woman
rather than be like you know like you
just said hold me hands okay you know
I'm gonna make mistakes um one day it
was to put the fishing rod out of me
like I was trolling here on BT sport
where I'm paid to know what I'm talking
about
I was trolling you for all that money
yeah I just feel like that guy who comes
from a similar place to you hasn't kept
the grip of or at least that's what it
feels here as someone like looking at
him well what's good what's gonna happen
is is that with the with the incident
you know it was it was factually wrong
and so unfortunately for real whether
he's got the right people around him to
save us in real you know what as fetch
it maybe we should just you know maybe
just like ease off away from it because
I remember when I had a go at and he
causeth learns about Andre marina
getting so much stick it was
fear for the newcastle friends to give
him that much dick and put him under
that kind of pressure they came from
mums I don't think you I think was the
support for dual ended a new supported
poetry that I really didn't help much I
think about it is is that we'll get on
to now but I'd honored the flow we need
some the real thing because it's not
really it's not I cannot sit here and
defend my because it was factually wrong
what I find very surprising we've
worried that he continued to yeah and
now it's maybe something that if he in
hindsight he wouldn't do
he again if he had the opportunity
wouldn't do because what it will do and
you saw there was a lot in the comments
there was a lot of people and they
weren't just Newcastle fans because what
happens is is that when you see got so
many people coming giving you the facts
and the facts and what's going on like
me I've been wrong on Twitter and so
many times I'd like to think not
factually what I'm doing because I've
got people around me that won't let me
get into a situation where you say
something what's not factual
Kelly Cates is good with that -
absolutely brings you right up right is
wrong in Kelly case straight in there
and so when you've got that so I know
that I'm safe in that respect then when
I'm wrong maybe abusing or because I
have my moments where I just hammer
somebody I'll know he's been a dick you
know I mean and people come say rightly
man come on your big and actually you
know then you've cleverly and they say
BAM sorry that was wrong sometimes you
just need to do that what you what you
have to know it's and I know that they
made my leaders to Alan Pardew right
it's something that obviously wearing a
muppet I was on your podcast about this
cuz usually I drink I ring in their name
by Jose no he's not doing that bad now
as I will know that yeah there's some
times it was terrible it was terrible
was going on with him and he was a my
Ashley man and if we're gonna go go go
deep into it but the fact is he's
somebody that I've known since 83 84 and
I'm not saying I'm backing him and and
some of the poor displays and what
happened at Newcastle just because he's
my friend but anybody will know that if
you've got somebody that is your friend
and your your in the media
you cannot hammer him like that you
can't cent you can't put him away
because Alan Pardew himself has been
upset with me because I remember we had
to have a discussion one week before we
did a date debate show when was doing it
because he didn't want to do it with me
because he fought the summer of things I
said about him in the past he didn't
like because we were mates and this is
where a new cast of friends if I
understand I'm up I'll be balanced
I will not with the fingers all right
sing it with every new classified won't
understand that your misra pods from
back in the day and I don't think anyone
would have everyone's got a heart and
everyone's got mates and everyone
understand but when you're literally
spouting incorrect facts yeah that's in
the words of urban ears we're talking
about Fox barks all right you're
chucking [__] but the thing is this is
what I'm saying you can't defend that
mmm and this is why it's very surprising
because I've worked with him and I know
that he's very meticulous in what he's
doing but I'm not gonna make excuses for
it you know I mean he's just come back
from the maldis maybe he's head still in
the clouds I don't know what happened
but I would love you no matter when you
say it sometimes is off guard but like I
say the only thing for me is that I
think that once it started to get into
the realms of the people are starting to
question your credibility then somewhere
along the line in respect of management
somebody should be pulling out because I
know my favorite thing real said of
everything when you read I mean why buy
you to 30 million poker players when
they get injured yeah and I was like
what what happens little fact so just
just come out the day I we're on the
subject I mean there's no castle early
in 178 million were made in the last
year Wow and we're now the eighth
richest Club in youth and in Premier
League oh that's their assault well
God's good available hm V's what my
actually said a year ago is I'm gonna
make every penny available
it was obviously clearly making a lot of
money where - eight million in the last
year were in profit so that's good night
now we set the record straight on new
cars on those what's it like when have
you ever been on set when someone is
just absolutely challenged it and you
just have to pop mileage here you sat
you sit there and you're just going what
is he doing like you are going husband
some awesome eyes
yeah no no no something or is there of
it like next time you see Rio you're
gonna be a little bit like resume is
like well to be honest so it will just
be will just be normal because I won't i
won't say anything and I'm sure he won't
bring it up just generally just one no
no you're a pundit thought surely you
said there I'd say more more early days
but I'm not gonna [__] sit on out
people do you like trying to get me a
slaw cakes sort of comrades no but not
asking for actual name last conformism
and you know what happens when you sit
down you hear somebody saying something
what you think that that don't sound
right
mmm then you're you've got you've got a
predicament you're in a predicament no
simply because your muscles Ashera
Janice I don't know if you remember this
she rushed to me and Janice down big
time on something he said about was that
Chelsea Spurs yeah but Sharon is got
that sir he's got a filler he's got to
feel Ernie's
he's like that you know I mean look at
me it's [__] you know I mean it's
it's brilliant to see him smile these
beautiful models get see nothing
I love seeing him I love seeing him
happy but he's one of those people that
if he hears bollocks he's [__] not
having it and and the thing is [__]
wait wait wait that's what you should do
some [__] gifts oh [__] we should do
some gifts way back ever since I've
known him he's never sat there people
talking saying something and he said
bollocks
yeah he won't sit there and listen to
maybe Jermaine talking about yet
Tottenham deserve to win it because
alidade they've conceded four goals how
can he deserve to win again conceded
four goals yeah well the way they played
facts are they conceded four goals how
can you deserve to win a game you know I
mean so that's the thing without and
with me like I was saying the point with
me is that you hear them saying and then
you've got to put a problem where you
can think now do I have to do I say well
you know what happened there was and
then you correct them [__] people on
the television then all of a sudden
you're thinking right might be a
[__] move and you've got limited
time as well you know I said yeah so
then you're so what should happen but
from a production point of view you
should not be on there unless you've got
the facts of what you're gonna be
speaking about so then you know so
that's sent to you reset you do that you
do quite a lot orissa specially no new
management anything like anything what
we're par for me I've got a girl [__]
fly solo with you - I don't know what's
coming next
oh you'll find out but the fact is with
us we if I've got a doing match of the
day and we find out what games we've got
who have gotten and we'll find out who I
want to speak about and then bam we
speak about what and then we find out
what we're gonna say and we that's what
we do when it comes to being a hunter
right nowadays we know you in cheer
especially as a the faces of English now
that you guys are the ones who we look
forward every weekend pretty I mean
there's other ones on there but use
other ones everyone's favourite Samira's
day but there wasn't always like this
thing you had a period of time where you
weren't really quiet and the hey John
you know and I remember being like what
the [__] happened yeah because you were
this huge name huge face and that all
sudden when really dark really quiet
what happened there you know and bright
is there was a time I was at match of
the day and it was the jester thing he
was was at talkSPORT
yeah and I've done a piece for talks
Paul and I kind of like I ran it off I
came just went off on I've got things to
say sitting at the end we've got Hanson
then you've got our and then you've got
me and then what what would happen is is
that Alan would say something then I
would say them when it comes to me it's
literally done mm-hmm and then you know
the things what I wanted to wear things
what I would say then I've made
jokes then people with social media was
about as much as it is now probably get
slaughtered because then people say
what's he adding what's he doing because
I find that I'm on the end and there's
nothing left to say and so I remember
doing a piece talking about listened I
don't like this rigid BBC I'll go to
Alan first you know I mean and then he
takes up all this stuff and you know I
mean every time I say something someone
full of [__] upstairs at the BBC
comes out says yes we need to see in
right he's said something that we're not
really happy with and this and that and
you know yeah I mean and then it was the
same thing I remember like Paul skulls
and I mentioned the word paperwork to do
absolutely the word screaming was said
on work would the busy before any told
about it is is that what happens is is
that was is it the duty log yes yeah
so only if three people we're talking
about as how many people 60 million
people mean if three people say I was
offended by Ian Wright saying this and
railing so that happened brought guys on
a nearly or any time I was on that
happened it got [__] Jarrah it would
do so angry well they telling you how
dress did you say well to be honest
there's certain things you do they
weren't telling you how to dress but
like your like your mannerisms and stuff
you know they were trying to they were
trying to haul me into this guy this guy
will be the one Mark Lawrenson
it wasn't even be the next month whether
or not but it felt like I was being
cajoled and danced this way and so I
blasted off in this piece talking about
it and then what happened was is that
the BBC obviously dropped me and then
what happened was is that obvious did
I'm not feel a bit unfair to you at the
time you ain't got no one to back you up
yeah anyone to I didn't have not one
person come out and say yeah in rights
right you know I mean you don't you hear
what he says you don't know anything
that's why yeah he also did seem like he
was a jester hmm you know so what's that
to happen was is that I've left the BBC
so I couldn't go to ITV because
got rid of me now Sloan who's now like a
father figure to me no II went to ITV so
you can get work ITV so so in the end
that's where I do a show oh yes shut out
shut out so you ended up having to do
stuff in Qatar for four figures
al-jazeera
a time or something and I was doing raid
Lord there's a quick that's kind of
where our lot get banished here that
Richard keys and you're like this that's
what you see when you're know it that's
where you go [__] off Dom come on top of
it but I kind of what happened when I
went there was because you had such a
short amount of time to try and express
yourself and say stuff is that make a
much longer time to do stuff and then
what I done during that time was I just
started to read more and just be more in
depth for what was going on because I
wasn't on telly and in the end I just
thought well I just I just want to know
more so I just blasted into just getting
more and more and more to the point
where I remember ITV wanted to do the
same guy no soul and wanted to do a
piece on Lori Cunningham he's life and
you know I mean Lori Cunningham is a big
hair of name yeah he was the one who's
the one I looked up to as well as
Cyrille Regis in the guys and so I said
well we can write snowballs and so at
the time I kind of I kind of said to
them listen I'll do it but some said you
got to give me another blast then it's
you've got to give me another blast you
know I mean so it went like that excuse
me and Sonia and they said okay so I've
done that show and it went really well
people really loved it so I was great to
see in my aura television again isn't
know and so they got all that kind of
feedback and then they gave me Chelsea
vs. Brentford and I was with Martin
Allen which was like a [__] home run
because I don't know what the [__] he
was talking about he was like he set you
up the look mate couldn't have gone any
better and so honest and from then from
then it just just went I've got another
one go know what I want and then all I'd
done during that time was just
continuously worked on researching and
making sure that you you're factually
now that's that's where I am so that's
how that happened and that time I wasn't
in it I missed it I miss not not being
in it I've doing a bit of radio and
stuff like that but I'm crying because
you were always the that you had your
own TV show I remember watching this is
your life with you yeah when I'm out me
and my body's got so much personality ya
know I couldn't believe it because the
footballers were just boring to me but
then jus I mean give us what happened
Brian because all of a sudden I wanted
to do my badges right yeah when I
finished playing I had the time I had
the money I did the time to be able to
do the badges which would take two years
to get everything done because all I do
now is question wonder if I could have
been a manager I know it could it be why
not why not why not sure if I had the
leadership qualities and now that I
didn't take the badges to get myself in
the arena to try it's a question where
you know I'm quite pleased I don't have
too many regrets but this is a regret
and I I didn't have I didn't have the
believer to say no no well I have the
balls to say to those managers at the
time no no no I'm gonna take a couple
years off and but then you got them
saying things like I mean a so Sounion
that's how I went to the television
reluctantly you know when I first
started yes I was doing people like
Denzel Washington Mariah Carey Will
Smith and it was fantastic just named
then those yes Rock knows him because
I'm soon on the tree so was it cool so
what happens is that you're doing and it
was brilliant in fear when I pressed him
away but then that kind of ease ease off
and then all sudden you you you get you
got you go to the BBC and then they want
you to to do stuff but we kind of yeah
we don't really want it to happen right
so then they're trying to mold you into
this again and so yeah and I started to
lose my way with it because I don't
really deep down want to do this this is
not really what I want to do on to be
doing football stuff and so you're in
these contracts you have to wait till
they finishing him once they finish I
stopped I lost my opportunity to be to
do the coaching because I watch it now
and you see people getting sacked after
like months and just [__] ridiculous
and you know you think yourself could I
do it would I be able to deal with the
press what are we able to deal with
and like an owner like that it's not
giving me the opportunity in their
capabilities to would you to do a DJ I
don't even tell you that I'm honest I
don't think I'd be a good manager
because I haven't got the patience I
haven't got the patience for it and like
you know yes I've been doing poetry for
a while and I've been in that warm nice
warm booth where everybody everything's
everyone looks after you one looks after
you t-wayne likely exactly one thing we
haven't touched on which you explain
what you were doing but you went from
football football football football and
TV football and then all of a sudden
like very little mm-hmm
a lot of people describe that feeling
like when you're just doing you're not
doing what you've always done it's like
a bit of a life changing moment was
there ever was there a moment where it
got to be like what the [__] am i doing
what was that like so many times so many
times simply because I think the reason
why I dealt with it as easily a lot
easily easier I should say then people
have been in the game from the age of 16
yeah and then you retire at 36 like I
did is because I had a life before so I
wasn't like all of a sudden retired and
now you know gambling and drinking and
stuff like I didn't do that you know
yeah I was I was more active in myself
you know I mean I wasn't a doctor just I
was I would my sliding door moment like
when it just to quickly go back to
Palace I got a good job I had Sean
Bradley as Bradley is just about to was
just born and Palace came for me and I
turned him down three times
hmm and I told his story all the time
because I didn't want any more rejection
when I went to Brighton for six weeks a
big stolen Bora to try and get down
there scored in their first team game
scored in reserve games it didn't happen
and it was the last time I wanted to be
rejected so when Palace came I turned
them down three times and I remember
there was a time when I was the tunnel
refineries and I went to have my man of
my lunch at his egg sandwiches egg rolls
those crusty rolls I remember it because
mean that men at mania the foreman we
never ever cross paths in the canteen
and this and I used to do this thing
where I was just [__] skiving really
I walk up there as quick as I can says
people's always working but I just got
up there find somewhere to just loaf for
after now and not do anything here and
then that is my kinda grunt I mean and
then I'll just walk down there with like
real purpose of people say busy doing
stuff but I was just [__] finding
another place to describe in this
particular time we I love the idea
reason walking really quick and they go
he's going off disguise my favorite
disguise oh you just sit in the toilet
in the canteen together and by this time
I've been asked by Crystal Palace twice
to have this two week trial and I'll
turn them down and I was sitting there
and he said so what's that mean said no
nothing why she said what's going on so
what's going on with a foot were you
playing said yeah it's going really well
your Palace said I offered me you know
for me that trial again any woman man
I've offered you that's the third time
now you know I mean let's say something
to you that's sprained to him what
happened at Brighton the fact that I was
really afraid of rejection and going
back to the community for another trial
and and everybody in a community saying
you know [__] him you're good with us
what he's [__] when you got to that was
a enjoy shame that the you do you think
do they enjoy being late yeah you're a
bottle job now you walk into the into
the dance and everybody's in there where
he's just come from Brighton he's only
good you know you hear those things you
know my brother would hear a lot more
Rumble to get into a lot of
conversations and arguments about people
digging me out of him not being used
when he come from Brighton so when I had
a trial for Palace I just said to him
will you be able to keep the job for me
but for the two weeks because obviously
new kid which is Bradley Sean was like
free and eight months off just come out
before and I said I literally can't
afford to lose this job you know I mean
he said yeah and I literally went to
Palace the trial thinking after two
weeks I've got the job Duncan [__] 22
the 22 yeah man
two kids mmm 22 you you're risking it
all playing a game of football I vomited
my other balls I tell you what was
really one of the
vivid vivid memories of I have of it is
the I remember when I to go to the trial
on a Monday I was having a bath in the
morning and Bradley would always come by
Iman always coming to Bob and can
continue to eat the bubbles out of box
and if I put an art apart when he come
back crying so I'd like to bring him in
to try to explain to him to not to eat
the bubbles out the bath and I remember
in there I'll just you know it's really
never told anybody but I remember he was
sitting there just walking around his
little party pants on and I was telling
him what was happening I'm going to you
know I'm going for another trial Brad
you know I'm gonna go to Palace to
Brighton one didn't work out and you
know just to be continued sometimes you
just need someone let me know just so
Tim I said I'm just gonna [__] go for
it I'm just gonna go for it and it's
really it was at a time where Palace
needed me or a striker cuz Andy Gray was
playing up front and moved him into the
midfield put me up front after a ball
bright in but I went to the trial and
once Steve Coppell said I'm gonna sign
you for three months after I've been
here for two weeks guys tears the tears
flooded down I do a lot cry I cry a lot
I've noticed and and then what's it
called the only sign me for three months
no sign me for three months but that is
all I needed once I got in and honestly
love the people when I remember still go
to the parties and stuff like half the
games and you [__] going it and the
people from the end you know I mean the
people from there was so [__] proud
now because remember we had David Rohl
cast was doing his stuff for us and just
thought it was the same areas you know
what we grew up on the same estate song
you know and when that happened you're
speaking to the older guys that old G's
you know about what and they saying this
is where you we can't be seen in it
senior news places too regular it
shouldn't be coming here this is your
chance you've done it you're in don't
[__] this up then you score like a
hat-trick on your debut or something no
was a tour came off the bench and scored
against Oldham bar so uh you know had
that feel it was again emotion yes they
were singing for me to come on I kept
coming off the bench as a as a
substitute in a couple of games and I
really blasted it when I came on it
opposed I think in a couple of
it was exciting for the palace fans and
remember we're losing 2-1 against Oldham
we had a player called Kevin tail oak he
scored a goal from a midfield and I came
on I caused all sorts of problems and
then I remember Alan Irvine a member in
yeah played forever and and everything I
remember went down the right side and
cut back onto his he's left left foot
and he swung one in and I just had a
fart pulsar led in and I remember they
are four weights then I ran from there
all the way down clapping and thanking
them for cheering for me to come on and
that's where my affinity with the fans
came from because and the fact that you
know if I'd done something was a nice
little bit of skill that oh so it was
just like it was perfect the perfect
place to show off every Saturday you
know you ever shot just whistle pass ago
ah they loved it it was like it was
dream and I second the perfection that
other funds
any little thing they're like [__] me
right now man honestly get your fellow
but it was see it was it was it was you
know it happened so quickly remember
this is something I've wanted since I
was a child and it happened in a space
of two weeks and you know let's know
listen let's say happening is in the
space of six weeks after oven under
two-week trial you know all of a sudden
my life has changed and having having
two kids at that point was that on your
mind when you entered the pitch because
for me I have me now remember when I
went offshore and shot work in a dad age
pressures on you in terms of like if
people offered like needing you to
provide for them or whatever but could
you wipe that out and just be like
football once you I was very fortunate
because I love it so much once I was
playing you kind of forget what's going
on on the outside and you really really
do especially I had so much to learn as
a striker remember I come literally come
off the son of a [__]
learning of making sure that you keep
the ball in certain areas making sure
that you're not doing you're not trying
tricks in areas where they're gonna win
the ball and get your defense and it was
really tough because when you got people
like Jim cannon old hard
Scottish Center are from Mickey draw and
George would and all those guys [__]
absolutely slaughtering your halftime if
you gave the ball away it was this is
where Steve Coppell I know Steve Coppell
couldn't wait to move those guys on
because they were suppressing a young
vibrant Palestine which everybody saw
come rise up in in in in the late
eighties but there lot of pressures no
no tensions in the jessamine yeah
because the old guys were very much very
very like jealous of the young guys
coming through excuse me so would any of
them make a mono and so like hey as Hugh
and like really have a goal and stuff
yeah a lot I think when Mark Wright came
he was like a more experienced older
black guy you know they kind of
respected a bit more because for
whatever reason the nicest man into what
he's a bit imagine brighty giving it
back if someone who's not gonna give it
back in a you know in a brace of way
aggressive way he's respectful he's
gonna be respectful right anything to
tell you in a way that you know how you
should do how Martin Luther King Donnie
how you you're you're being a diplomat
yeah you know right it was basically the
guy who I commented with for the first
time ever and he like took me under his
wing and that in there it mark right
turn me into a professional person he
was the one we roomed together
you bet cardigans together wear cardigan
he looks like a good to see how you
bring together yeah we were together for
years it's so funny though in the MRC
Tommy is have you roomed with you've
roomed with some big names well so Mark
bright Ben Kevin Campbell dennis
bergkamp
Paul Paul Ince of England and then it
got to a stage where you know he just
you had your own room which was my big
toe we did you become so senior that you
would just like look just give me my
sweet know I just think that it just
happened like that right it got to a
stage where I think that rooming
together was more a case of putting
people together so you can bond yeah
well so I've heard you like in that
dressing room cuz there's an image of
him in the me seems really like stiffen
a bit like you can't just chill
have a good time while he can could you
have a good luck for him yeah yes
pods and you know pods is one of the
guys that when we were in the meetings
he would be the one who would talk about
the taxes and what's going on what he
thinks should happen and how he played
he's a very average player and get me
wrong you know I mean it'd be what you
would call that holding midfielder but
unbelievable energy easily the fittest
guy at the Football Club at a time but
very he's an intelligent blog one of our
met so I think you know I'm actually
Pete Gibbons yes yes Big B
he went off a tour modeled from the
other night in a nightclub porches and
he was like oh you know my mate true
George and apparently podgy turned it
around in life yeah because he didn't
know what was coming I think partly
because Pete was absolutely off his tits
as well no you don't really want to talk
you don't really want Pete coming over
now is to say that he knows another big
you just say true Jordi's coming yeah so
what was your like best memory at polish
what's the time that you nail off a pod
think I think when Jim cannon left and
it was like you know me and bright him I
made Tony Finnegan Jeff Thomas people
like that John Pemberton Bucky that team
what got us out of the second division
and glass into the first division at the
time when we got into the first equation
we finished the third you know after
losing nine nil to Liverpool earlier on
that season we add a brilliant young
driven athletic team Jeff Thomas in our
captain you know I mean you know myself
and brightly upfront Andy Gray Jeff
Thomas in the midfield that was hard to
deal with young John Sulaco on the left
it was flying my Eddie McGoldrick you
know an ill Redfern before him and then
at the back it was Eric Young and Heath
um David Burke John Penn burn it was a
team that had experienced pace and we've
frightened teams who is there a sense of
like relief when they first left those
about the house when you the preseason
what we finished you know
the pre that the preseason the next time
might be in 88 or something
it was magnificent it was a joy to be a
food I was everyone just like [__] those
know what yeah it was it was it was a
joy because like
and steve kapur who was a young manager
they used to undermine him so it was
embarrassing for us in with them in you
know saying things to him and I remember
one time me and Jim had an altercation
on a training field and I went inside
and he kind of almost said to me listen
just stick it out keep going keep doing
what you're doing this is during the
times when he would say do not change
the way you play mm-hmm that's why we
signed you when you left polish wasn't
there like a bit of a sour reaction from
the funds they were nasty yeah yeah they
robbed Judas on my mom's wall which is
[__] terrible thing to do to Westing
lien jeez really just god-fearing woman
Jesus Christ it was what was that did
she ring you and tell you about that
what was I am crying I'm talking about
you know like obviously my brothers had
to rub it off the wall and stuff like
that but it was um it was something that
like the palace fans who I love you know
I mean like I got my man
is honey he's on breezy he's on Twitter
I loved him he was a goalkeeper that
when I got to a million followers he was
the first person I picked for there one
more game for the one more game he's my
goalkeeper Connie Ryan and why'd you
call him Connie because that's his name
right there fair enough yeah just check
it right so he is somebody that will
fight my corner
listen Arsenal like Mills the first team
I ever saw a football match at so I've
got an affinity with Newell Crystal
Palace I would love Crystal Palace's is
a girlfriend in the end you know
somebody that I loved and I asked the
wife is the one you married yeah a lot
of that had to do with David broadcast
because when David wrote cast was signed
for Arsenal as a youth team player and
we found out literally the whole state
in and around 80s early eighties you
know 83 84 think it might have been we
we everybody asked law as a team so to
end up playing there with him you know
as somebody that when we were younger
you know when in Emily's make Kevin
Arnold unfortunately both pass now that
imminent they used to trot we used to be
playing football at the CREM and they
were trying to sneak past because we
were oldest I was like four years older
than Dave and like we'd be for like 14
14 and like so then they're trying to
sneak past the guard play on the swings
and we say in go you and go that in
doing Cola and and david david rocco's
but they wrote castling go right and
dave roecastle would literally remember
what he would have been 9 mmm 10 they
broadcast will get the ball like when we
were kids and do that rush goalie finger
get a ball throw like that go through
everybody score a dog run barking
brilliant and you're still going he's
gonna go what about Elliot yummy but
like almost how good he was and that is
why I think palace fans feel that just
because I signed for Arsenal in like
everything I do is asked and driven they
think that I just just cuz I went there
well son I loved and that went that goes
back that goes back to David Rohl cos my
love for Crystal Palace and the Crystal
Palace fans that loved me people like
Steve parasite and loved him he's
amazing man unbelievable good love her
as well I've heard was a private time
enrollment no money changed hands but
somebody somebody who loves the Football
Club and he was these best times was
mine our brightest times in around Jeff
deist times and so my love for the club
is something that will never wane and I
say to people that the greatest the
greatest moment in my life would have
been if we were able to lift the FA Cup
in 1990 when when when we lost to
Manchester United you know I've gone on
to win the Premier League and the FA Cup
a couple of times and European medal
winners cup you've got throw these
things in because you've got to
otherwise it to Palace fans I'm leaving
to win things so if you leave and I
genuinely meant night happened within a
week from the time I was meant to go to
Aselton it literally happened
I didn't ask remove didn't instigate a
move I went to training normally on a
month he went in to leave couple and he
said we've accepted a bid well from
Arsenal sorry out and that quickly so I
didn't get to saying bye to them but
then when they done that to my mum and
then when I went to play against them
when I was stay saying a song
saying about my illegitimate see I'm a
bastard on this and I'm a dad it was
[__] hard to take and so you know did
you know I scored every single time I
played against Palace
I scored every single time and
celebrated how did that feel it's
[__] it's bittersweet because you
know I mean like I say Palace gave me
the opportunity you know I mean people
say yeah but you were good enough to
take it
Palace gave me an opportunity and the
fans especially the away fans he
sponsored me for most of my Palace
career sponsored my kitten sponsor my
stuff they loved me so for them to be
singing that and it was hard to take and
so you know celebrating and then kissing
the badge of arsal I fought that at some
stage what they were gonna they were
gonna boo and then they would clap me
off but they were still really quite
vociferous with there with this stick
towards me because I think that they're
especially they've been auntie's it was
a case of jealousy I went to ask then I
was successful and you know this is why
I only I cater for the palace fans that
love me I I've got no problems with the
the ones that haven't got no time for me
I've got like they voted me their player
of the century the last century I can't
ask for any more in there and so that's
that's indictment enough to make me know
what the palace fans have felt about me
but that was something when what they'd
done and what they sang it was very
difficult to be able to take in because
I was very nervous playing against
Crystal Palace and I remember there's a
time I think I scored a goal to one of
the seasons where they went down and you
know the palace fans gave me even more
sleep I remember saying to Nigel Martyn
on that actual day you know I mean I
scored the goal and Nigel Martin said to
me and [__] sake what you doing I said
I was trying to miss I said I was trying
to miss I [__] can't
[Laughter]
I mean I just say that I said no he said
alright you know just trying to miss yes
so you're talking about a sad memory
like football and memory what about when
you went Arsenal a new and rocky scored
one of the first games you play it
together well that's game I've ever
played like fairy tales just came over
planing because I just told you they ro
cast somebody that industry I knew David
well because when I went to turn him
school
David roecastle was probably in the
infant's so I got there at eight from
Gordon Brock and I got to the infant's
at Turnham so david rocco's would have
been any in the infant so that's how
long we go back he's in the same class
as my ex-wife and so that's how far we
go back so then for us to and he was a
Crystal Palace supporter so you know we
played all our football I remember there
was one time right was in the block of
flats and it was me my mate Clyde
roommate Conrad Conrad's brother Trevor
David Rohl Castle and and Kevin Arnold
so he came into the block because I just
into the block and he said listen we
played for a team called Vista right and
they'd the team that they were meant to
have it didn't turn up for whatever
reason so we had to go over to steel
nest school to play in this tournament
with these with these people with all
their mums there and all their dads all
their kit and everything and it was all
fit and it was me David
like I say Conrad is a good is a good
midfielder Clive it was a rugby player
and Trevor his little brother and Kevin
Arnold it was a substitute and they must
have been twenty teams here we won and a
young coach what we had and that's how
far we go back and we played so when
when it happened I was going a sign for
for Arsenal it was a [__] dream come
true because like I say David broke into
Arsenal and he was a magnificent
football man what he done there and when
when when I got the early week I signed
for us to went to his house and we were
talking about our slot until five in the
morning
Tottenham what it means not to lose
against Tottenham I've told his story so
many times and he was somebody that each
you mentioned Tottenham
so he can't lose against Tottenham Tony
Adams the same Merson the same Mickey
Thomas the same Kevin Campbell the same
everybody who came through he can't lose
against him we spoke about it so to
actually play in the game and then we
got to the game I was petrified man I
remember I played in the first game
forearm for us against Leicester and it
was magnificent because there's playing
different brand of football and I was
making moves but bull didn't quite come
because there's other people making
moves and John Holland's used to tell me
that when you play for a team with
better players what's gonna happen is
other people doing things and there's
other options is more options it's
something that I had to learn but it was
so good to play in that because your
touches and I was make him lose appeal
House scored and so that was the only
time I played in the number 9 shirt for
us because Alan Smith got injured in or
he didn't pass the fitness test and then
under Saturday Alan Smith came back and
then Paul Davis gave me the number 8 and
it was mean and the first goal was I
went through had a shot rebound David
Rohl castle's score the rebound and then
I scored a hat-trick in the game so it
was like and then I said something like
the broccoli boys that I don't know what
it was but it was the it was the best
football match ever it was like living
in the dream it was living in the touch
living the dream it was just it was too
good to be true so when I only played
him for a year when it came to the time
where he left as [__] I was devastated
because I literally went there because I
know he's going to be there and I kept
when it's training that morning and
David was outside I remember George
Graham saying it was the hardest thing
he's ever had to do so he was he was
outside and I saw him and it was really
quite you know it sees a jeté Tunisia
and I went over and as all over he had
tears in his eyes and I thought [__]
all saddened I thought something
happened family something and he just
said they're selling me [__] you know I
was gutted
Doce we both started crying again
because it was one of those things where
I genuinely didn't think he was gonna
leave it was just so it was like I'm
like mark Wright's saying when when I
left he said I did we didn't expect and
we didn't he just when something hits
you that like that bad and you're gone
I didn't expect didn't see it coming so
when when he when he when he when he
when he left I was shaken for about I
was wrong for about two months remember
Tony Adams Tony Adams you know I mean
when I went in and like I took on see
see the boss like I was crying when I
saw the boss and he's and he's doing his
big speech about he and that's what
happens in football you know he's doing
his stuff with his Jackson people move
on that's how it goes because maybe
[__] stuff I wanna [__] smile they
did he actually got told Lily got soul
to leave yeah and like I say it was it
was out of blue and in the end we kind
of dealt with it but it was a very
difficult one to deal with because it's
never happened
that's the first time I've had any kind
of setback he kind of shock in football
everything was just plain sailing up
Siddhant everything was brilliant at
Palace you know all my people around me
everything was great I was playing
everybody is great and then you go to
Arsenal and then all of a sudden you're
playing with your childhood friend and
you know he you know I mean any Salem
devastated how much longer how long was
it live for before you thought this
guy's diagnosis and well I think let me
see it wasn't when he got his diagnosis
it left leads by name because I went to
he went to when he came back from
Malaysia in his when he got on it when
the diagnosed when he was diagnosed and
it was one of situations where again you
know it was really [__] hard Brian
simply because he made a funky cold and
so he's speaking like normal like this
so lymphoma it was Hudson's lymphoma and
it was a it was a finally said it and
way he spoke when he was when he talked
about what it was kind of made you feel
like oh okay so it's fine he said yeah
yeah young and gone checks gonna be fine
your deenis in that and so from the time
that ii was diagnosed till you know he
passed it was literally at a time what
they say it was gonna happen but when he
was younger than you as well so you're
so yeah so young guy you know time soon
yeah so he's he died when he died he was
33 and i remember what the hard thing
about it was the phone calls that you
know because I can hear you know when he
spoke in the voice it was a croaky
huskiness that was you couldn't help but
you know to tears you know you couldn't
help it and he'll be the one trying to
let you he'd be the strong one
have you always had such a powerful
memory because I'm I'm shocked it when
you're accountings you the egg salvage
like you remember so much detail it's
the problem from Mormons he bites the
moments that those moments literally are
they changed my life ah so that's what I
could remember what I was eating at a
time you know and with David I can
remember literally every single phone
call and it's difficult how did you how
did you like get through that I don't
think I have a car because like even in
this kind of setting now and you take a
minute me
tissue yeah when when I think of the
phone calls how are you speaking and you
go back to your childhood sorry bro
take it take a second man I know it's
hard for you go back to your childhood
and then you realize what is cheers nice
one nice one I mean [__] [__] oh [__]
you think back to when he was 9 and 10
mmm and all those kind of moments and I
remember when I saw when I saw him in in
in the coffin ground it's a it's an
image that I've since then well you know
you go to funerals and they've got them
all I cannot I cannot look inside them
because I can't I can't deal with the
fact that a PHA for he was gone then
he's he's family you know his girls and
Ryan he's sighs unbelievable wife Janet
you know I mean we're still very much in
contact but it's it's something that it
take things like that happen to the best
people it's [__] one of those
situations where I'm very god-fearing
and you know I mean I had to because my
mum was and we had to do all that stuff
but that's when I had my arguments with
with with God you know I mean like
remember saying I was speaking to Brad
Bradley when he was a child I can
remember having this [__] screaming
match to speak in in a room about taking
him and taking kids and you know with
this terrible disease and and it's just
other no [__] it makes you question
life month really does it does and the
thing is is that with with religion and
all that sort of stuff you have to have
faith I have faith it's things that
happened and they continuously happen
like you know when when something
happens in another thing happens and
and you think what the [__] people I
mean when I was younger my mum and you
know they always got saying you know
God's not gonna give you more than you
can handle and you think to yourself oh
really because this is you know this is
really quite tough mm-hmm you know to
try and get answers for why David
roecastle gets taken at 33 why kids get
cancer and die you know I mean why
people appearance to go through the
[__] [__] what you have to go through
when you know you you you you're
pregnant you're desperate for a baby and
the baby comes along and in [__] two
years the baby contracts I'm like why
would why don't people have to go
through things I remember having that
kind of argument just swearing and the
thing why I do my praying like because I
do
I'm god-fearing and I just at the same
time you know I mean I'm very very you
know what's the word I'm looking for
Lawrence when your philosophical not
philosophical the other one where you're
not quite sure
okay sticking away you say you believe
in it and a god but yes because I think
that's been ingrained in me right too
many bad things happen to me bad things
happen through religion and things like
that and a lot of stuff happens through
religious religious beliefs and so you
do question that sort of stuff and then
you question like you know I was hearing
it would have been was it Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan said you know I mean [__] if
scientifically you think to yourself you
know I mean yes we were a certain kind
of monkeys walking the earth we [__]
at some mushrooms and the open that
brings up you know I mean is that
anymore is that any more [__]
outlandish than what people say about
how Scientology came about or the snake
and Adam and Eve are talking flying
snake is a Neanderthal man walking
around and all of a sudden starving you
know walking around and found some
mushrooms at the mushrooms talked to his
mates then they start eating them they
get more wisdom and this and that
because their minds are open is that any
more [__] out
landed and listening to Adam and Eve
being the Crips oh no those are the kind
of things that I talk to when I speak
and I don't want people think [__] me no
but when people die what's that fellow
Turkey Christ David when people die the
point is you contemplate life me and
that's what you certainly do is you're
thinking what the [__] am I here for why
are people dying who are loved and we
all have these [__] thoughts it's
just you're you've got the balls to
actually say it and say I sat in a room
on my own and I [__] had a
conversation with whatever was on it and
try to reason with what on
what did come of that conversation man I
think that the mere fact that I was able
to just being there blasting out because
I was on my own because you know this is
these are the times where like you see
like now probably one of you finished
some stage on I like my moment again
where I probably have a another
conversation because it happens like
that because the David roecastle death
it's something that I don't think I'll
ever get over I will never get over it
and so you say what came of it I don't
know but I think that being able to say
it was it was it was something that kind
of gave me a little bit of got it off my
own chest sometimes I feel like out of
that came to pain and I've lost a lot of
people on me might I lost my young
cousin 22 years old 24 years old none
you're looking at this kid and you
thinking you had it all you know you
know you're just taken away from you I
kind of feel it when you're feeling like
I we do grow from that I can't have that
kind of pain and and get through it
without growing from it you're just not
what you're sitting doing seems to me
like you're just fine in a way this is
why this is why I do feel very fortunate
with the waste gone for me
you know I mean honestly and and now
I've got a now got a missus my two
little girls you know I've got a missus
that is just amazing guys you know
that's very she's perfect
in respects of the person that I need to
be with and even even the way we met in
a pub a cow and not Neal you know I mean
it was a time where I was split up with
my wife divorced in our lives they're
going to make bodies who is a dear
friend of now and I remember I went in
there and that essaouira and remember
I've been involved in a 20-year
relationship I remember when I told my
mates I met someone you know I mean
obviously being as close as close to me
as they were knowing that I what I've
just been through what I've just well
I've just come out of there were very
very [__] come on just just relax and
just I know I know because the reason
why I knew once I got her interested to
do my clothes they are if you're not
gonna dress then what's the point we
have such an affinity with other like
there are a lot of guys that you know
that dress in a very outlandish way sort
of you know I see you out and you're
you're very suave dress and now you hang
around with a lot of people who are
maybe questionable yet you know there's
a lot like a sakes about girls like
missus but mock say to my girls just
dressed like you're just getting dressed
in the dark whatever you feel you want
to put on put it on I saw an advert the
other day where a guy got dressed in the
dark and I can't mine what the advert is
I don't promote it on here but I thought
what [__] good idea man yeah I'm
gonna do I'm going
do that at some stage and that's why I
was making with my missus is that it
wasn't it wasn't like her back she
didn't know anything about what didn't
know anything about me I tried to my
mate introduced and I just persistent
persisted and to the point where you
know I mean I fought she's not gonna but
then in the end I mean we're sitting in
the Cowen town said to give her a course
it just come for a drink just come for a
drink because she did for a bit but then
she say hello and I try to get in and
the track buy her a drink she's never
take the drinks and that's fine like
I'll get my own and and so it was really
hard work and I remember every I
literally could not stop thinking about
her every waking moment everything what
was going on was thinking about her and
plus I was with him all the time so you
seen it what's going on ever until in
the end we got to go man it was the it's
the greatest thing I've done what made
you persist because she was the one and
I'm new shoes the one cannot can ask
about new season generally your
relationship history though because
clearly as you said you weren't very
good at it not at one point why were you
not very good at it and why you you
could had it no guidance I remember
earlier on I served in Ewa gardens you
never big I didn't have a Big Brother
guidance a father guidance that made me
realize how to respect women and how to
treat people and did you get that
guidance though or did you learn it
because we know yeah I always feel like
not learning I didn't love the dad
figure so I became him something that
eventually I didn't know I didn't and
you know you know I mean it sounds like
we're about to burst in a song I did not
know what love was yeah didn't get
loving in a way that made me realize how
I'm gonna give love because the kind of
love I got was I don't know I can't even
remember I remember saying to people cut
them from a certain age can't remember
getting a kind of a what kind of
affection affection and a motherly kind
of like till I started [__] playing
football everybody was all over me you
know I mean [__] if I got downstairs
I the first place I bought from I'm on
the top floor if I got downstairs and I
said listen I'm downstairs I need to
come up [__] probably come and come
carry me up you know I mean and before
that you know I mean you couldn't get
the time
they are people Britain you know I did
not get love I didn't know how to give
love and it's something that I'm still
learning because my wife came from a
very supporting loving family you know
and I didn't know how to express what is
it like being around that family now for
you and you see how they are around each
other in your little sad hmm very sad
very sad you know I mean even you know
I've got me and my sister up to this
that we don't speak I'm spoke to my
sister for and unweaving to come in 15
years Wow because I've got I've got
relatives who up just sort of cloud of
me life yeah well my sister was very
disrespectful to to my wife when we were
younger when I when I when we just got
together she's very disrespectful
because I remember we got together it
was a we were together now and my sister
obviously she's she she knew my ex-wife
and my and my kids and so she felt like
she had to take a side which I couldn't
understand because I'm a brother and I
remember we I to do I to fill in for
Russell Brand doing Big Brother's little
brother that show and she said she
wanted to come and I said listen well
missus gonna nights gonna be here and I
said I don't want no I don't know
[__] seen I don't need to be
disrespectful or rude if you don't got
anything nice that just [__] don't go
off don't speak to her don't do it and
what she done
I remember sighs all dived under so
everything's fine bringing us earlier
and everything what she done was a Nancy
you know such a sister Nancy like
because she's a decent person went to
introduce herself she totally bribed her
in front of people
Nancy versus that totally blanked her
right saying something about I have to
be I have to be true to my niece and
nephew totally blanked her so remember
this has happened while I'm doing shows
I was right in the greenroom and so when
I came out Nancy Cedeno was her what's
happened was my sister you see my sister
and I said yes I'm aware she said well
she she understand what happened and I
tell you what you see like I say about
Varkey and I'd never hit a woman
would never hit a woman when I was young
we're talking about the the restraint I
showed with her when we were kids the
point when I went over to her at this
time right this is why I know I would
never because I was feeling [__] from
my toes Brown that anger I could feel it
because I asked her specifically and
she's like my mom she says I don't give
a [__] about anybody that's how my mom
was that's our seniors they've faced
either in people's faces and I went over
to her and I said as long as we live
I don't want to ever see you again and
then only time I will speak to you is
when you apologize to her and she said
I'd [__] apologizing to anybody and
say well that's fine because that's good
I will never have to see you again or
speak to you again understand to this
day
no screaming people say life is short
and you know people we people might be
listening to this thing yeah but you
know no there's certain times that
people themselves have to realize you
yourself you have to realize that is
wrong
yeah we've been together for 15 years
now you know I mean happily 15 years
seekers should see that this woman is
the woman for me
somewhere along and the [__] irony is
Omar brighter together her and Mark
brighter together now turn turn turn
I'm [__] it you know I mean so that's
what we need so what what happens now
what happens we don't to know companies
mark right is somebody that is a big
brother somebody that I respect as a big
brother is guiding me they're together
now what's gonna happen what's gonna
happen they're getting married
what's she gonna do she's gonna
apologize before she walked up the aisle
because it's not going to be acceptable
here do you ever think about that as
especially as I could god-fearing man
someone who believes in forgiveness I
want something to happen in that respect
because my missus doesn't deserve to be
treated like she's one of the greatest
women in the world stand that Yeah right
so at the end of the day my sister and
her attitude from the time we were kids
to to now that she's still not spoken to
me who's done
thing but helped the family and
everybody in everywhere I can still not
found the decency to realize that she
should have apologized by now people
will say come on you've got forgiven no
because you know if you go down that
road with her again and she's shown no
remorse that you're likely to get more
Eirik later on in it so it's all you
know what the thing about it is is that
we've accepted that she's you know what
I've always accepted that I'm not gonna
be in and around her because if the way
she's grown up is the way she is now
then I don't want to be around that
person but she's my sister
and you know I mean it shouldn't be like
this no you'd like you'd like to have a
loving relationship with her I'd like to
have a relationship with her because
she's my sister here but you know what I
can't do that because my principles say
and what I said that day is what I will
stick by until you speak to her and
apologize and tell her that you're sorry
for happened in which Nancy would
probably say it's not a problem that's
fine I will never speak to her again
was it weird for you that she's with not
bright of all people yeah but the thing
about it is is that marks such a decent
bloke yeah knowing that we've not spoken
for so many years didn't when it
happened a few years back and he phoned
me to say to me I mean me and your
sister be gonna become an item you know
will you help you and he said that the
[__] delight from because I didn't the
day I'm happy for him and to a certain
extent [__] happy for her because
she's got a decent bloke mm-hmm amazing
cardigans you know I mean I love this
car TT bright although yeah he's
somebody I love and I just want him to
be happy but like I'll say that's just
like I say we're on here and while I'm
in this what mode I didn't that's what
I'm gonna tell him this is why it's very
it's very easy for me to open up to look
like that because once I started seeing
that lady Rosalyn Craig
she said you speak and you let get it
out what you're holding it for you know
get it out you know make people know
what you're going through people need to
know the journey if you are willing to
give it to them you don't just pick up a
lot of these things inside you you're
helping other people at some stage
somewhere along the line people can was
get in touch usually here this brightly
lit she might listen to you she'll find
out that's a [__] olive branch she's
just got their rope deep because
throughout your story I'm sort of struck
by the fact that there there's a lot of
chance in your story that you have no
met the right people
than this other thing and you say you're
you not necessarily religious but you're
a spiritual like god-fearing it does
seem like how often do you sort of like
a bit look up and think like someone is
looking after me or like that's
something because there's a lot of
things where you're saying it and you're
teaching it as an older guy than me like
you're you Stratton is a very good
teacher yeah I'm I'm not same in a bad
way but it seems you've stumbled across
a lot of very spiritual conclusions not
through going to church not through
doing these things but just like you've
come across them in your life Church and
gods in your heart really this I when
when people say about going to church
and you know you have to be in singing
doing your stuff you know if that's what
you want to do that's fine but you know
the spirituality the spiritual vibe I
have is is still one where I can still
question the faith the main thing at the
end of the day is to have faith because
that's what he wants it's not going to
just do something where you're gonna see
a miracle and then you think oh my god
there is a God why would he do that
because then everybody would just say
well there is a God son let's do that's
not how easy once people righteous
people to come to him to find him and
beef have faith in that and like I'm not
preaching to people I'm not telling
people to go to God or go to church and
just saying my journey is that way I
think of it like that I feel that
there's something just like I feel that
we may have found mushrooms you know I
mean this is what I'm saying so the
question lies there is so much chance
and things that's happened in my life
you have to think come on man he's right
so much [__] luck story though innit
whereas someone lost at sea and then the
bulk of ships come along and he goes do
you need a hand and then you go and say
Oh God's gonna save us and then third
becomes long and then he goes dies and
he meets gardeny goes sent three [__]
bolts
that's it so what the mushrooms send my
god
are we getting wrapped up now bro are we
do we have or are we okay I've got three
more questions alright really
can't we do a Joe Rogan just keep will
you get some mushrooms what we do a pot
to I'm thinking because there's a lot of
[__] I wanna there's so much stuff we've
got we've got a long list of stuff that
we just asked you smash this we want to
be favorite podcast you ever first time
you last three questions if your if your
life was a movie hmm
what would be the middle point of that
movie what would be the turning point
for you where you're like the beginning
about it what's the prison mine because
I remember I have to do the television
show with football behind bars mm-hmm
and I remember I asked them because I
had to go back to chills furred si-wing
and it was a second cell in and I said
to them because I remember when I was
night when I was leaving that prison
cell Brian I remember Saturday and I
said I will I will never ever come back
to a place like this ever
right and I remember going in there
because they were losing it and I said
can you just lock me into this one and I
sat there and I felt so [__] proud of
myself all right I had all Kinsler oh
Jesus Christ man cuz I remember lying
near when I was 19 with not a clue what
I was gonna do when I came out not a
clue so I'm sitting there to finishing
up wrapping up his show and I said to
just lock me in that one for like it
said five minutes cuz the [__] you get
very close to five minutes and I thought
to myself all the memories came back I
remember when I was in there and they
locked the door you're on Liberty is
gone your Liberty is gone you're sitting
there like an animal
almost and I remember sitting there
dressing like Guerra you know I mean I
had my long car my hat on and it just
came back to acid I'm [__] proud of
you man really proud of you well done up
to this point up to that that particular
point
if you had to choose between being liked
or respected which one would you choose
respected because I think that when
you're respected you're gonna have to
upset some people you know to get to get
to gain your respect I think when you're
being light that's just [__] very in
it it's funny as long as you actually
don't really have to choose mmm because
you've got the liking and the respect
people love your hair so that's it it's
funny but like you know you know looking
at there when you look at the comments
you get so much [__] love sometimes
around and then you see one person so do
you [__] prick you know I laugh at
myself in that respect I laugh at myself
but I think if anything you're doing if
you choose to be liked over respected
then you still got some living to do do
you think you add a little bit at one
point you know when you're talking about
going to the entertainment side of
things that was the time where it was
about being more liked than respected
what do you mean well you know when you
went into doing TV and entertainment and
those sorts of things a lot of people
were trying to shape you into a guy like
my jester yeah yeah yeah because I
remember watching you as a kid there was
a show what was it ferns like news no
the guy with the beard it was a it was a
panel show like a football sport so it
was owned one where I was really fat guy
used to host him Rory Rory yeah he was a
nice guy Brandon yeah Romig refers in it
and you told the story and it always
stuck with me is I think it's all over
they think it's all over right and you
tell this story about you had a new
Ferrari and you turn to whoever was in
the Ferrari with you and you were
hilarious
that was how can you laugh about
crushing a Ferrari
funny story about teachers but
absolutely to me you told this so I tell
you what it was it was a time I bought
this Ferrari mod nur a convertible one
and I was so [__] upset with his car
cuz I had a black Berlinetta which I
should never have sold I should have
kept it to this day
I've got rid of it and bought this
stupid blue convertible Ferrari and the
finger Ferraris now you've got a button
on it and I must I got in so much
trouble with the insurance because they
didn't want to pay me out they've got a
SR button on it what you you have to
switch off and I add it for I'd say
eight nine months and it's literally
like a tiger with no teeth with that
button you start driving it he just goes
slows down unless you turn this button
off right so I'll be trying to sell it
and I bought it for something like 117
grand right and the guy what the guy who
sold it to me said this is the one this
is the one what everybody wants
if you come back to me in a year I'll
give you I probably give you your money
back for it
something in the air brilliant I went
back to him you said I could give you a
hundred so anyway so drive but I'll take
miss a side button off and I was with my
nephew Shane and we're driving up this
hill and it's got a really nice little
chicane II bit in at the top of it and
so we're driving up on us if I said to
Shane Shane watch this havoc boom
floor it over turn turn it to the right
[__] back inside so I try to get the
already rolled over as we can slide down
and then I remember there's a there's a
fellow on a ladder st. it's just really
stupid
there was like paparazzi there and
everything at the end in the end cuz it
wasn't so funny
money comes to money
these prick footballers I tell you
honestly I believe in God after that I
would I would have died in that all
right me last question
hmm is how would you like to be
remembered it's pretty easy for me
because I feel very fortunate to get to
the stature that I've I have kind of
carved for myself still like I say get
respected by people but I just want I
want to be probably remember for for
somebody who just got the opportunity
and done the very best of it I wasn't
the most educated guys I've constantly
had to learn along the way and one of my
biggest I'd say one of the things that
my biggest hang-ups is is not paying
attention and staying in school to the
point where I could educate myself
because one of the things that people
used to say to me a lot was it can't
string a sentence together you know he's
you know it means you know you need
lessons you know he's [__] and that
would be something that when I read
those kind of comments it used to really
very insecure about that so I've kind of
had to along the way just try to educate
myself and make sure that I just want to
give people value for money so what I
would say about myself is I just want to
be remembered for the perfect for the
person that got the opportunity and did
the very I rang it out I rang it out
there's nothing left in that right to
squeeze out and that's all I want to be
remembered for
it's been an absolute [__] pleasure
thanks for you've got to come back I
can't come back to talk about my new
castle and what you know I mean I will
do that I have to do that if anyone
wants to see more Ian right he's got his
own YouTube channel now shout I will put
the link in the description below so
they're great citizens they can
subscribe to the Ian Wright YouTube
thanks guys I'm really pleased to Geordi
Brian avi people
bringing cheers everyone say subscribe